[Musique]
alors que le monde a les yeux rivés vers
l'ukraine qui subit une menace militaire
et une invasion russe
le chef de la diplomatie européenne est
avec nous il est sur france 24 pour une
interview il est aussi josep borrell le
vice président de la commission
européenne haut représentant de l'union
pour les affaires étrangères et la
politique de sécurité
il décrypte avec nous la position et les
initiatives des européens bonjour
monsieur borel en duplex depuis
bruxelles à la commission donc est ce
que dans cette invasion de l'ukraine
vous aviez imaginé que vladimir poutine
irait aussi loin
qu'on le craignait mais il avait
toujours dit que non non non jamais
jamais de la vie ils allaient envahir
reclesne c'est ça qui avait dit au
président macro chancelier allemand il
avait de ça fait tonner toutes sortes
d'assurances que c'était pas question de
mahir le plein et voilà à l'issue d'un
conseil européen exceptionnel les 27 ont
dégainé des sanctions qu'ils qualifient
de massives sanctions financières qui
n'ont pas l'air de convaincre vladimir
poutine pas plus que les précédentes
l'ont empêché d'entrer en ukraine
avait d'abord fait ses censures l'avons
pas arrêtées demain
l'invasion plus dé monsieur poutine en
ukraine mais ça va faire du mal très mal
à l'économie russe ces effets vont se
sentir dans le court terme mais sans
doute pas appelée des mains donc on
pensait pas évidemment que ces sanctions
allaient arrêter la guerre mais l'union
européenne utilise les moyens qu'elle a
que sont des moyens économiques
financiers diplomatique politique on
n'est pas une union militaire on agit
dans le domaine civil et on a plus de
mesures fortes pour isoler la reçu du
système financier international pour
empêcher des finances et des la ruche
pour arrêter les exportations de tous
les biens qu'ils sentent très important
pour son développement industriel et
technologique
et la sanctionner c'est à dire on
interdit de voyager on agit bel et bien
d pas mal de personnalités russes il ya
tout de même évidemment tous les ex pays
de l'est qui pendant cette réunion des
27 ont fait entendre leur voix plus
fermes notamment la pologne il y as on
parlait aussi d'interdire finalement aux
russes le système de réseau
inter-bancaire swift est ce qu'on va
aller jusque là et pourquoi on n'y va
pas tout de suite d'ailleurs
tout est sur la table
ryan a été définitivement refusé mais on
est dans une approche de la duel serré
hier il n'y a pas eu le nécessaire
consensus pour prendre ces mesures ceci
ne veut pas dire qu'on va pas la prendre
plus tard mais
vous savez l'union européenne travaille
à l'unanimité je vais présider
maintenant le conseil des ministres des
affaires étrangères qui doivent
approuver formellement les paquets
conseil européen donne des orientations
politiques mais ne prend pas des
décisions concrètes c'est nous les
ministres dans le conseil qui vont le
faire et tout est sur la table en
particulier la liste des sanctions qui
sera qui sera pas
on dit d'ailleurs que aux précédents
rounds c'est à dire en crimée en 2014
l'admirent poutine a pris l'habitude
finalement de se passer puisqu'il a il a
coupé ses voies d'approvisionnement
d'être plus autonome sur
l'agroalimentaire
sur sur reconstituer son agriculture
baisser son sachar jean dollars et qui
le rend finalement beaucoup beaucoup
moins sensible aux sanctions financières
il faudra connaître les choses telles
qu'elles sont c'est vrai que depuis que
les mais la russie a développé
énormément son secteur agricole
d'ailleurs c'est le seul
le gaz et pétrole qui fonctionne et oui
aujourd'hui c'est un grand pays
exportateur de produits alimentaires en
particulier les blés et c'est vrai aussi
que là on monte ses réserves extérieures
mais vous savez les tensions économiques
et financières
cible de cette très spécifique le
transport l'énergie la technologie là où
nos capacités
sur une arête de leur passé de les
exporter un hors jeu après si ça va
faire du mal au développement de ce
secteur pointe évidemment pas
l'agriculture
les pays qui sont voisins évidemment de
l'ukraine en premier chef évidemment la
pologne craignent une vague migratoire
des ukrainiens qui fuient le pays pas
par peur évidemment de cette guerre
est-ce que ça aussi c'est une
possibilité que ce soit d'ailleurs
utilisé un petit peu comme arbre hybride
comme on l'a vu pour la biélorussie que
ce flux potentiel de migrants ukrainien
c'est pas une armée bélie 2 vous savez
quand t'es mis en garde les gens s'en
vont
évidemment il y aura du kenya vont
partir et on fera l'impossible pour les
accueillir on a discuté de ça et la
commission mes collègues qui sont en
charge la politique migratoire sont
préparés pour aider pour faire face à un
flux migratoires dont l'importance on la
connaît pas encore mais ça c'est pas une
armée brise ça c'est tout simplement que
les gens quand il ya une guerre que ce
soit en ukraine en syrie ou chez vous
demain s'il y en avait ils partent
alors lorsqu'on a fait aussi ce les
allemands ont suspendu le gazoduc nord
stream que sa certification est bloquée
et or nous dépendons toujours à 40 %
loin ce qui nous concerne les européens
du gaz russe est-ce que ça va être
compliqué alors d'une part pour l'hiver
on nous a donné la certitude que non
rien ne viendrait à manquer mais en même
temps on va peut-être payé cette énergie
très très cher
toutes ces tensions dues aux politiques
font remonter les prix des produits
énergétiques que ce soit légal ou les
pétroles sa démarche et intégrer ces
démarches le maxi ou logo mondiaux et
mondiale et cette tension là évidemment
photo monter les prix du pétrole et
l'igas même source les prix sur ce la
quantité il n'aura pas le 2 mai payer
plus cher c'était des choses n'est pas
la voie c'est une autre
pour l'instant on appelait des mesures
cherchant d'autres sources
toute source de toute souplesse que je
n'ai pas trouvé les mots français pour
faire face à une hypothétique
coupure de l'impressionnant russe mais
pour l'instant on s'y attend pas mais en
tout cas on aurait les moyens de
répondre emmanuel macron a parlé
d'atteinte la plus grave à la paix à la
stabilité de l'europe de tournant dans
l'histoire de l'europe est ce que nos
démocraties sont pas en train de
démontrer qu'elles sont vraiment
périssables surtout si elles ne savent
pas se défendre contre des régimes
autocratiques très déterminés
à les petits en mode clan a fait une
excellente intervention arrière la
conférence de presse qu'il a donnée sans
pareil qui résume très bien créer un
lien ce qui est en train d'arriver
la guerre est à nouveau aux portes de
l'europe on croyait ce à une époque
passé révolu on s'était habitué à la
paix on avait renoncé on attend continue
à renoncer à la guerre aux façons de
résoudre le problème entre les vers le
ceta et voilà qu'une étape avec une
puissance militaire les fortes est
envahi son voisin qui d'ailleurs se
défend avec beaucoup de courage avait
beaucoup de force et qui menace
d'utiliser l'armé nucléaire on dépasse
la cites pas formellement mais tout le
monde le comprend à tous ceux qui
voudraient
s'interposer dans ce conflit
oui c'est une page de l'histoire de
l'europe
malheureusement rentrer dans une étable
beaucoup plus tendue dangereuse
démocratie sont toujours à l'air de
faire face à un conflit long des des
procédures de décision bien plus
différente d'un régime autoritaire au ce
la volonté d'une homme dans une
structure verticale du pouvoir qui
décident sont les mains des troquets ce
que les gens pensent
heureusement la démocratie on tient
compte des opinions publiques on tient
compte de la volonté des gens des
régions ne sont pas n'ont pas tous les
pouvoirs et les processus de décision
sont évidemment plus long et plus
complexe
ça nous fait plus faibles non c'est ça
nous fait démocrates c'est la démocratie
à l'avant thèse les gens puissent
évaluer et changer ce gouvernement c'est
pas le cas des régimes autocratiques
même en même temps on a envie de dire
josep borrell on était un modèle aussi
pour les ukrainiens pour tous ce flanc
est
et aujourd'hui eh bien on se demande
jusqu'où va aller vladimir poutine
pourquoi pas en moldavie en géorgie il
est déjà il détient déjà la biélorussie
est-ce qu'il va reconstituer l'ex urss
le président poutine sens de l'histoire
n'ya qu'à lire ce qu'il a écrit sens de
l'histoire ce qu'il dit c'est pas dès
aujourd'hui c'est l'alléchant certain
nombre d'années 2007 munich la
conférence demo nicklas d'éclairement
qu'est-ce qu'il vous pensez faire l'a
toujours considéré que l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique c'était la plus
grande 10 grâce le plus en valeur la
plus grande tragédie pour la russie est
d'une façon ou d'une autre ils essaient
de reconstituer les glaces issus
de la russie en essayant d'influencé
absorbé contrôler les pays qui
souhaitent et fait partie de l'âme de
l'empiré tsariste d'abord le lien se
fait tic après qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant en ukraine comment ça
va se terminer cette histoire
les ukrainiens se battent et se bat avec
beaucoup de force de courage l'armée
kenyane ne s'est pas effondrée et les
combats sont acharnés et évidemment là
le sait pas quel va être le résultat
mais le souffle d'un registre
merci à vous josep borrell d'avoir été
en notre compagnie sur france24 merci à
nos téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivis